hey 42 here you were once a kicking
screaming tiny little human I know it's
hard to believe right since you probably
can't remember a single thing about
being a baby most of your early
childhood is probably a memoryless void
and the few events you do remember are
likely hazy this phenomenon is known as
childhood amnesia and it happens to
everyone some people are better at
remembering than others but we're all
pretty bad at it but why is it so hard
to remember life as a baby let's find
out it's believed that memories start to
form in our brain as soon as we're born
and maybe even before however studies
have shown that small children don't
actually store those memories
permanently so that they can later be
accessed in a de life we don't start
storing memories in a somewhat
semi-permanent manner until the ages of
four to seven we can usually remember
certain important events that occurred
between the ages of four to seven but
before the age of four nothing in fact
during a study children between the ages
of four and seven were told things that
they definitely did and said two years
prior but none of the children could
remember doing or saying them most of
the children actually said that wasn't
me it was someone else
infamous neurologist and pioneering
psychologist Sigmund Freud believed that
we repress our earliest childhood
memories because this period of time is
so full of psychosexual content that we
simply wouldn't be able to handle such
disturbing memories even as an adult but
nowadays that theory carries very little
gravitas more recently however new
theories have emerged that attempt to
once and for all
explain this mysterious childhood memory
loss the first of these theories is that
as an infant our brain quite simply
isn't sufficiently developed yet the two
parts of our brain necessary for forming
new memories the hippocampus and the
medial temporal lobe are already well
developed by the time we're one-year-old
however another part of our brain
called the prefrontal cortex doesn't
fully develop until our early 20s it is
believed that the prefrontal cortex is
responsible for creating episodic
memories which are memories of actual
events being able to remember what
happened where it happened and roughly
at what time it happened is a skill our
brains don't master until later on in
life until this time our brain is only
able to remember skills we've learned as
well as cosmetic things such as items
and faces as babies we aren't able to
attach emotions to these things so they
don't transform into events and are
therefore less memorable another theory
that compounds this effect is that as
babies we aren't able to talk we have no
language that's quite significant
because it means we were never able to
represent memories with words for
example if you think back to the day
when you moved into a new house you can
probably remember certain
distinguishable aspects of that day such
as the house had six windows and a blue
door and you arrived at your new house
in a small red car if an infant were to
be placed in the exact same situation it
won't be able to attach words to the
event because a baby has no idea what a
window or a door is never mind how to
describe them
so the infant wouldn't be able to make
that all important link between words
and memories which is what we do all the
time as adults psychologists think that
by attaching language to memories in
this way it helps our brain to organize
and store them more efficiently so if
we're able to describe a thing or an
event with words it's considerably more
likely that our brain will remember it
several years down the line by the time
the average child reaches four years old
it knows about 5,000 words that's just
enough to be able to describe most
things and events even if those
descriptions are rather basic it doesn't
matter it's still fuel being added to
the memory tank this process of
attaching words to memories is further
reinforced by the fact that when we
learn a language we're then able to talk
about things
scene with others and every time we talk
about something that's happened we're
much more likely to remember it in the
future that's why your granddad has told
you the exact same story about when he
was a young lad or hundred bloody times
and continues to do so every time you
see him because it's told it so many
times that it's not impossible for his
brain to forget it
these theories do have some weight to
them and they're widely regarded as some
of the best theories we currently have
to explain why we can't remember life as
a toddler but there's brand new evidence
that may once and for all
definitively explain this phenomenon we
all know just how much scientists love
to answer questions by experimenting on
rats and this question is no exception
in an experiment scientists controlled
the speed at which rats brains were able
to make new brain cells they found that
when they slow down the wrapped ability
to generate new brain cells the rats
were able to form more solid clearer
memories and they were able to recall
memories easier conversely when they
sped up the wrapped ability to make new
brain cells the rats were more forgetful
and their memories became fuzzier now
before you asked how they were able to
test rats memories let me explain I mean
they couldn't exactly interview them
could they the scientists did this by
associating the place with a mild
electric shock then observing how the
rats reacted when they returned to that
same place in the future but shouldn't
it have been the other way around
shouldn't the rats who have their brain
cell production rate increased have been
able to remember more not less well you
would think so but here's why it's
actually the complete opposite just like
a computer hard drive our brains have
limited storage space there's only room
for so many brain cells so our brains
ability to store new memories is limited
this means that when new brain cells are
created if there's no more space
remaining then they have to override old
ones so when a new memory is created if
there isn't any spare room our brain
decides which memories are useless and
can therefore be forgotten and it
deletes them to make room for the new
memory oh and before you say we're born
with so many brain cells and weak
on grow new ones that rumor simply isn't
true research has shown that brain cells
and neurons continue to grow in our
brains throughout our entire lives
although the process does slow down
somewhat as we age so why does this
deletion of memories occur more often as
an infant than as an adult two reasons
the first is that our brains are
developing at an astonishingly fast rate
as a child we are learning and
developing faster than we ever will in
the remainder of our life so a lot of
room needs to be made for new memories
and skills that we learn secondly a lot
of what we experience as an infant is
deemed non-essential by our brain
because let's face it you don't need to
remember the time you were on all fours
in the garden and you try to eat a chew
so all these useless memories we create
as an infant of the first to be
discarded when new memories are created
and new skills are learned as we grow up
so to summarize we can't remember being
a baby because our brains have emptied
the trash because our hard drive was
getting rather full thanks for the view
subscribe for more 42